while in Florida some of the Democratic
hopefuls are spotlighting the nation's
largest shelter for unaccompanied
migrant children senators Elizabeth
Warren and Amy Klobuchar visited the
facility in South South of Miami
this week some immigration advocates
have described the conditions inside the
privately run shelters as quote prison
like Manuel Bojorquez is at the facility
in Homestead Florida mainly one of the
challenges here from a reporting
perspective is tracking everybody so do
we know how many children are there
right now well good morning so far what
we know is there are 2,300 unaccompanied
minors ages 12 to 18 at this facility
which is not required to be licensed or
inspected by the state you can't see
much from the outside so advocates who
are concerned about the mental and
emotional well-being of those children
are showing their support however they
can for months protesters have been
keeping watch at the homestead facility
we give them hope we know that they know
that we're here that we are fighting for
them that they're not alone day after
day they stand on stools and ladders to
wave to the unaccompanied migrant minors
on the other side of a fence the number
one crime is keeping these kids in
detention in large numbers in inadequate
quarters around 2,300 migrant teens
mostly from Central America live under
these tents located next to an Air
Reserve Base court documents filed last
month by lawyers who were allowed inside
the facility allege there are prison
like regimens and conditions here which
are causing clear ongoing psychological
harm hope fry is one of the lawyers it's
a military internment camp and we don't
run those in the United States of
America last I heard caliber the private
company paid by DHS to run homestead
issued a statement that the candidate
visits are attempts to mislead the
public and score political points
it said the physical and emotional
well-being of each and every child is
the shelter's primary concern fry
disagrees she says sometimes minors are
held here for months and that violates
the so-called 1997 Flores agreement a
set of rules which limits detention of
minors to 20 days but the Trump
administration argues homestead does
not fall under that agreement because
it's considered an emergency temporary
shelter homestead should be shut down
immediately and forever closed we should
stop warehousing children for the profit
of companies homestead officials say the
portrait painted by the lawsuit of
conditions inside is quote entirely
inaccurate but critics like Frey argue
that having a for-profit company run a
shelter like this may be incentivizing
them to keep the minors here longer than
necessary the company says it must
release those minors to a vetted sponsor
vetting takes time they say the average
stay is 35 days Gale all right man well
thank you very much